Wrestle open your favorite beverage.
And take a seat in your giant baseball glove
leather chair.
Because LÜT is back.
When you're as hungry as a horse make sure
to use this "hungry as a horse" measuring
tool so you'll be sure to get enough food.
If you're still hungry but are too lazy to
write down a shopping list you can use this
voice command grocery list maker that will
also print it out.
Just remember to add these edible bugs.
And be sure these anatomical chocolates from
Visual Anatomy are on there as well.
You can get individual body parts or order
an assortment of them in a box set that includes
kidneys, brains, vertebrae, and even a colon.
If you're experiencing problems with any of
said body parts you can decorate your IV bag
with these IV decals from Little Love Medical
and customize your pack so you can get some
leopard print ones along with these cool comic
book themed ones.
Never be bored again after strapping on this
simon says belt buckle and playing with yourself.
Or let your cat play with this solar powered
cat toy that requires no batteries only the
power of the sun!
Or CAT-apult them with these combat catapults
where you build your own catapult and battle
your friends by throwing a camera at them....
ok...
You'll need a nap after catapulting cameras
but be sure to first warm your PJs up in this
PJ warming bag.
And then fall asleep in comfort and privacy
with your hoodie travel pillow.
Wake up and tell yourself you're awesome with
this chalk mug that you can write on.
But even with that the neighbors probably
still have better stuff.... doormat.
Because they own this awesome bulletproof
couch bunker.
There is a fire-rated gun safe hidden under
bullet proof cushions that can be removed
and used as shields from bullets.
So yeah....
Continue to be awesome and use this human
slingshot and go fling yourself
Or make your own zipline with this kit because
you've always wants to zip yourself...
Let your kids use the zipline while you read
"how to not kill your baby."
While in the yard put out these adorable skeleton
garden gnomes that are sure to scare away
all of the squirrels.
If that doesn't work maybe hanging this wall
mounted squirrel head will do the trick.
Luckily it matches your squirrel print throw
blanket.
For less death-defying activities get some
of these tiny paper dinosaur fossils that
you can build yourself.
Or try to buy things with all of the money
origami you'll make with this instructional
book.
That you keep safe, organized and genetic
in your DNA shaped bookshelf.
Which will go nicely with these cool drink
coasters made from recycled rubber fire hose.
Recycled firefighter dot com up cycles old
firefighter parts into everyday items like
and ipad sleeves, pet collars, and duffle
bags.
Always stay in touch with this fire fueled
battery charger for your phone and other electronics
called FlameStower.
Check out the kickstarter page for more info..
But first - remember, commas save lives.
You're welcome, Grandma.
And as always thanks for watching!